I'll begin by talking a little bit about
how I got into this project and I'll
start by saying that that work earlier
work I did for the book on rape I was
really a huge help for this because I
trained as a rape crisis counselor it's
in Vincents hospital just to do the
interviewing I wanted to do it
sensitively I didn't want to step all
over the feelings of people who had
already been trampled and it was a
10-week course
and invaluable to me and so that because
when you're interviewing victims of
trauma of any kind as some of you
clearly are with your projects of course
you've got to be very sensitive and the
last thing you want to do is reach Roma
ties them or take control away from them
or make any of the mistakes that are
often made by the people who surround
the news victims for lack of a better
word but when I went into this project
about the soldiers I didn't know I was
going to wade back into the field of
sexual assault
I was just firstly I just really wanted
to do something about the Iraq war I
wanted to use myself as a writer to
write something about what this war was
doing and initially I was interested in
conscientious objectors and I started
following the Iraq Veterans Against the
War when it was a brand-new organization
and when I first met in their hand we
had 30 members around the whole country
that's huge now so I went to one of
their meetings and it was at their own
about 12 people in the audience and they
were talking about their the the guys
were talking about their experience
there's in the early war you know they
were this was only a year or so into the
war and they were already veterans and
there are a couple of women standing in
the back of the room not saying anything
so I went up to one of them and said are
you a veteran too and she said yes I was
in Iraq for 11 months and I was a gunner
on a tank I was shot at every night but
you know what when I tell people nobody
believes me nobody listens to
and you know why because I'm a woman so
I said well I'll listen what was it like
to be a woman on the front lines like
that and she said well I'll tell you
there are only three things the guys
that you be if you're a girl in the army
a bitch a hoe or a dyke
and then I knew okay I've got to follow
this and that's sort of when I
discovered my story so her name was
Michaela Montoya she was with Mexican
American only 21
from LA East LA and she was just a
terrific person and she was my first
woman soldier and and through her I met
others and then I went I met I gathered
my other sources through various
veterans organizations and sometimes
they would lead me to friends and then I
also began to publish articles and then
women soldiers would write to me and say
this is my story and I'd write back and
say can I interview you and then I would
meet them and it would go from there so
I ended up interviewing about 40 women
who'd served in Iraq as well as some had
served elsewhere and some men and and
out of those 40 I picked five to
concentrate on because you can't tell 40
whole stories in a book you know the
reader would be instantly lost and then
in the play I I actually picked seven so
I expanded it a bit and I weave for
those of you who haven't had a chance to
look at the book I wanted to show the
full spectrum of what war does to people
and including why they would enlist
which was my initial curiosity why would
a woman want to be a soldier what makes
her do it so I start with their
childhoods and and so you understand
what drives them to enlist many
different causes which I'll get into in
a minute follow them through training to
the war in Iraq and then back home again
it was very important for me to get that
whole arc so you could see them change
so I'm going to start by reading you a
little bit of it and then oh I'll go
back into talking about it but it's
simple I wanted you to hear this because
to get an eye
dear of the style because I did
something unusual with this book which
is I didn't write it as normal
journalism with you know fact quote fact
quote I wanted to use my novelist side
and write it as a narrative as a story
because I want the reader to identify
with these women and care about them
it's very easy for us who when we read
about people who are in worlds other
than our own to distance ourselves from
them objectify them it especially
happens of course when there are
barriers such as class and race but but
even myth the barriers between being
privileged and being unfortunate lucky
and unlucky we don't like the bad news
so we push them away push them away and
and one of the great things that fiction
can do is bring people so alive that
they feel like you're relative or even
like yourself as you are reading them so
within the limits of nonfiction I wanted
to try and do that so that people
couldn't push these women away and would
feel for them so here's and there were
challenges I'm doing that but here's a
little sample about one soldier called
Jenifer sprang oh I'll give you a tiny
bit of background she's one of my five
Jennifer grew up in Wisconsin a small
town called Racine right beside that
Lake Michigan about an hour north of
Chicago her father was a fireman her
mother a nurse very working-class town
at one point had been thriving because
it had lots of factories and in the 90s
the factories all closed down as they
did all over America and and this town
just went spiraling downhill and crime
started to happen and unemployment and
drugs and it became a really dump of a
place so it everybody every young person
just wanted out of there and one of the
main ways to get out is the military so
that's that's her background so Jen
joined up at 17
her father very enthusiastic about the
military signed the waiver the fishery
was too young to be legally allowed to
sign up on her own and the next thing
she knows
she's deployed the stench was
overpowering strong enough to make Jen
recoil as she stepped out of the
military plane into the Kuwait night she
had no idea what it was rotting garbage
burning oil fields dead bodies she only
knew it smelled nothing like Racine
Wisconsin the air was so thick that the
inside of your nose your ears were
completely black she told me it was
absolutely disgusting Cramton exhausted
from 18 hours of flying
she and the other fresh soldiers filed
down the airplane stairs and into a
waiting bus it was February 2003 the
month leading up to the invasion and
they were to be driven to Camp Arif Jan
a huge US military base south of Kuwait
City to wait for the war on the way she
huddled her small frame into her seat
her blonde hair tucked under her army
beret wishing she could at least glimpse
whatever there might be to see in the
night outside but the soldiers were
forbidden to open the curtains or even
peek out she felt as if she were being
delivered to war blindfolded when she
reached the camp and climbed off the bus
she found herself in a vast complex of
warehouses and tents surrounded by coils
of razor wire to her surprise the desert
floor was as hard as a sidewalk but
covered with a layer of sand so fine it
puffed up like baby powder at each step
later she learned that soldiers called
the sand moondust she and the other new
arrivals were ordered into a long metal
warehouse the size of an airplane hangar
stuffed with thousands of green army
cots almost everyone occupied by a man
jen was to sleep an arm's length away
from her neighbor on either side faced
afoot to minimize the spreading of
disease if she needed a bathroom she
would have to weave her way across the
room with all those men watching her she
laid down and changed her clothes inside
her sleeping bag feeling a long way from
home the building wreaked of sweat and
feet and the musty tang of masculine
bodies jen was one of only four women in
a platoon of 34 men and one of 20
in a company of 213 she was to live and
work in close quarters with those men
for the next seven months camp Arif Jan
is known as one of the most dangerous
faces for women's soldiers in the Middle
East
built by the Kuwaiti government for
American troops it held about 10,000
service members and private contractors
when Jen was there almost all of them
male they call Camp Eric John
generator city because it's so loud with
generators that if a woman screams she
can't be heard said Abby Pickett who
passed through it on her way home from
the war they were saying the number of
rapes that were happening on base by
soldiers were very high and they told us
not to travel anywhere without another
soldier it soon became routine for
platoon leaders to order their women
soldiers never to go outside at night
without a female companion not just at
Arif jam but on all bases many resented
this including Staff Sergeant Liz o
Heron of Madison Wisconsin who is in
Iraq with the Air National Guard in 2006
quote they tell us after we hit the deck
from an incoming mortar shell that we
shouldn't walk alone at night on base we
as in females how am I supposed to track
down another female to go eat when I
want to shower when I want females
aren't exactly crawling around this
joint screw you you deploy me here and
tell me it's not safe for me to walk
alone to get a bite to eat because I'll
probably get raped by one of my own so I
chose that quote because it does really
show the attitude of the women which is
there in their core tenanted dilemma
many dilemmas but on the one hand
they're really invested in being tough
self-sufficient and being soldiers they
have to as one of them just I just
talked to a female marine a couple of
days ago she said when men men prove
themselves in boot camp once they've got
through boot camp then and they've made
it they can do whatever they want women
have to prove themselves every minute of
every day and then they don't get rid of
this for years even way long after
they've they've left the military
sometimes for the rest of their lives so
on the one hand they're really invested
in being tough and on the other hand
they're being harassed sexually
assaulted and raped and such high
numbers it's breathtaking
the statistics I found among veteran
studies are 30% raped while serving
that's almost one in three one in three
75% sex should be sorted 90% sexually
harrassed the little word about the
harassment harassment isn't just teasing
it isn't even on the level of being
browbeaten and harassed and sexually
verbally tormented at work it's much
more intense in the military because in
the military you were living with the
your platoon 24 hours a day week after
week month after month sometimes year
after year there's no going home from
the office early in the war the women
were sharing tents with the men they
didn't even have their own quarters they
had no separation from the men ever
anywhere so and they're vastly
outnumbered the numbers of the ratios
altering a tiny bit now but for most of
the war in Iraq only 1 in 10 troops was
female and they weren't necessarily
deployed together or anything so
sometimes they would just be handful of
them among hundreds of men or as in this
case I quote read you a little quote
from one of the other soldiers I
interviewed called Chantelle like micro
tune had 60 men and one lone female me I
was also the youngest still 17 because I
was the only female men would forget in
front of me and say these terrible
derogatory things about women all the
time
I had to hear these things every day I'd
have to say hey then they'd look at me
all surprised and say oh we don't mean
you one of the guys I thought was my
friend tried to rape me two of my
sergeants wouldn't stop making passes at
me everybody's supposed to have a battle
buddy in the army and females are
supposed to have one to go to the
latrines with others
showers but because I was the only
female there I didn't have a battle
buddy my battle buddy was my gun and my
knife so the isolation also leaves them
very vulnerable and thus when you're
outnumbered and you're isolated and the
men are constantly undressing you with
their eyes making vulgar sexual remarks
day in and day out making passes at new
sometimes being threatening and when a
lot of those men are actually your
superior in rank and of course the
military hierarchy you have alt all
power over those who are lower than you
in the ranks this eats away and eats
away and eats away at you and studies
are showing now that just the harassment
alone can cause 9 times as much
post-traumatic stress disorder as combat
so because women have got this double
whammy and of course it's not happening
to all of them but it's happening to way
too many they've got a double trauma
they've got the trauma of the sexual
harassment and persecution and they've
got combat so it's not surprising that
studies are showing that women soldiers
have double the amount of trauma that
men men coming home and is is the VA
paying attention to this is the
government giving the VA enough money to
help with therapists and so on of course
not so we've got we've got a sticky
situation I'm gonna backtrack a little
bit and tell you another reason why I
was so interested in women and this war
the Iraq war represents a huge
historical change for women in the
military women have been fighting in the
world not they're not fighting women
have been part of the military in this
country for over a hundred years which a
lot of people don't realize but for most
at that time they were nurses they were
auxilary help they were up doing
paperwork they weren't even allowed to
carry weapons until after Vietnam but
and then after the draft ended
Kennedy President Kennedy at the time
gave this speech about how great how
wonderfully the women of great women
were and how wonderfully they had served
in the country because it's like we
didn't open up more jobs in the military
to women we wouldn't have a military
anymore so all of a sudden women were
valuable and then they began to open
more and more and more jobs to them but
not ground combat ground combat is still
illegal it is banned by the Pentagon
this is banned by our government and now
we have Iraq women are in calm ground
combat all the time in Iraq by the third
year of the war if not earlier more
women had been wounded and killed in
Iraq than all the other American wars
put together so it's it's huge - huge
difference no I mean soldiers no
civilians are the whole other that's a
whole other story
women and children do do get killed the
most but that's another story now
Congress is finally waking up to this
ridiculous paradox where we've got the
army on one hand with all the military
all the branches giving women medals for
valor and battle well at the on the
other hand saying you're not allowed to
be in battle I mean this is the
situation we have now which meat which
is very dangerous for women not because
they're not getting quite the proper
training that some of the infantry get
which means they're more vulnerable but
they're also not getting the recognition
they're due and they're getting all this
harassment so they Congress is actually
having some hearings about this next
month that I'm supposed to testify at
least that's the last I heard so at
least somebody's waking up to this
ridiculous paradox what we're going to
do about it I don't know the Pentagon
claims that this country isn't ready to
to see its women being soldiers and yet
it is and I love the Pentagon is amazing
missus schizophrenic organization I can
think of because at the same time as
saying that and this the same document
it released
the reason we ban women from combat is
because the public of America is not
ready to see its daughters and mothers
in battle it released a study in the
same document that showed that 73% of
the public was perfectly willing to see
women this battle
I guess they hope nobody would read it
so there you go
but that's another reason I was drawn to
this because I because it's such a
unique and different kind of war for as
far as women soldiers are concerned but
back to the effects of the harassment
and the rape the thing that really broke
my heart about this is that since war
was invented the great compensation for
soldiers has been what camaraderie
brotherhood and brothers as Shakespeare
said it book after book you know you've
you've seen about how the bonds between
soldiers and the great love that's
arisen between them and how there's
nothing like it how can you feel that if
your brothers are harassing you in or
raping you so where does that leave the
women when they need to depend on these
guys to watch their backs in battle I
asked them this and they said it leaves
us alone and that's why I came up with
the title the lonely soldier so we're
asking our women whether we believe in
war or not this is the reality we're
asking our women to go out there
sacrifice their limbs their mental
health their all their physical health
and sometimes their lives and not even
has that that camaraderie again I don't
want to sound like I'm talking about
everybody there are there are exceptions
there and they're women who have good
experiences and will will fight me to
the death and on this subject and say
you know oh you're exaggerating and
everything the ones are the best
experiences tend to be the ones who work
in medical units
one of them said to me I'm in the curing
business not the killing business there
are more women in medical units but also
they can feel better about what they're
doing but I've had hundreds of letters
from women soldiers saying that's
exactly how I felt alone and that's a
huge part of the why they fit are so
traumatized when they come home and the
picture when they come home is very hard
because they're haunted by the civilians
they've seen killed the gruesome sights
of dead bodies and burned bodies on the
streets in Iraq the people they've
killed themselves sometimes just being
part over an over machine that is
killing civilians a lot of soldiers
don't understand why we're in this war
or do understand it and don't like what
they understand this is not a war full
of soldiers who believe in it and you
know what the most soldiers I've talked
to in red surveys about say is I can't
even think about the politics behind
this I can't even think about the reason
for it all I can think about is staying
alive and keeping my buddies alive my
mission in life is to keep my buddies
alive back to the camaraderie and
because women sometimes have a harder
time making that point because they
don't have those bodies and because they
are the outsiders the other in the
military occupying in many ways the
place that african-american soldiers
occupied in World War two and earlier
and still occupying some units because
the you know the the racial blind
military that they like to boast about
is a crock because they're already
outsiders there's something very
interesting about women when they talk
about war women soldiers they see it in
my view with clearer eyes than men do
because they're not so invested in being
defensive and loyal they're not so
defensive they're not so invested in
building up this war
all but round their band of brothers
that locks out civilians a wall of that
won't let criticism of the warren that
won't let you know what were you doing
there why were you letting yourself be
used to kill people and I have found
women much more open ready to face those
hard questions than men and I think it's
because they have less to lose you know
they're all because they're already on
the outside so I wanted to tell a
different kind of war story I mean I
wanted to tell the war story through the
eyes of women soldiers she doesn't
hasn't been done in this country before
because we didn't have women soldiers in
the same sense now that doesn't mean you
know of course that they all have the
same view even among the five I chose
there are those who are much less
concerned with the politics of the war
and its purpose than with how they feel
the soldiers themselves were mistreated
at the beginning by being given really
bad and inferior inadequate equipment no
armor for themselves no armor for their
vehicles
well how they were treated at home
screwed by the VA not given that the
benefits they were do you know cheated
left right and center I mean it's a
nightmare dealing with the VA and it
always has been so some of them were
more focused on the rights of the
soldiers and that's what they're angry
about less on Iraq or the civilians and
some of them really did put a lot of
thought into what we were doing to the
civilians and why then one of the most
interesting along those lines is the
woman on the cover of my book Ellie
painted crow she is as you couldn't tell
from her name Native American and she
had been an art in the Army for
twenty-two years by the time they they
deployed her she was a grandmother and
these are the people we've been sending
to this war 42 years old seven
grandchildren and we send a war but it
was so desperate for bodies she was a
drill sergeant high of a high-ranking
Army sergeant army first first class
and she'd always like the army it had
allowed her to make a better life for
herself and for her sons and in fact she
had liked it so much it encouraged them
both to join when was the marine one was
in the Army once they were grown up so
she went off to Iraq with some questions
but feeling that her ready to do her
duty this is how she'd been trained and
one of the first things that her
commander said to her and the other
soldiers was it's Indian country out
there go get'em so she said to me I
thought if it's Indian country out there
maybe I'm on the wrong side she started
to get interested in the Iraqis and on
the base where she was there were some
Iraqi civilians working and she had the
job of escorting them on and off the
base and they had a market set up right
around the outside of the base where
soldiers were allowed to go and buy
things like magazines and junk food and
souvenirs which she said were all made
in China and um she went out there and
she started to to talk to them and they
were very intrigued the Iraqis because
quite a lot of them speak English they
couldn't forget her out and quit she had
her uniform on and her Sun goggles and
her helmet no they kept saying are you
Indian new Indian from India and she
goes no and they take off your
sunglasses we want to see your eyes no
and then one day this boy came up there
and he'd just seen that film Dances with
Wolves he said I know you're an Indian
you're a red Indian and she laughed and
said yeah I'm a red Indian he said no no
Native American she went yes and they
slapped hands and then he invited her to
eat with them in the market and she said
this was extraordinary because when she
looked at the food a lot of it was just
like the food of her people same kind of
flatbread same way of cooking chicken
same use of sage and then she started to
talk to them about their tribal system
in their hands
and the significance of the moon and she
found more and more parallels and this
broke down that barrier that all
soldiers are trained to have to see you
know the enemy is the other a subhuman
it broke it down and she just felt these
are my people I'm killing my people and
it completely radicalized her so now she
talks about this war as being a genocide
as far as she's concerned and she's
become a huge peace activist and has
held drum circles in Washington DC in
front of the White House and she's
really become you know an amazing peace
activist and also someone who helps
women veterans but it was because of
that but I have that event that happened
that she could say she could break down
the barriers that have opened her eyes
to that so her story is in here and but
the others or the other thing that
opened up a lot of eyes was the children
because the children in Iraq are always
running up to the soldiers and they're
begging for food and water and they're
adorable
they're like little children everywhere
and a lot of them were mutilated and
wounded
you know we drop cluster bombs all over
Iraq even though it's against
international law to drop cluster bombs
on urban areas you know what cluster
bombs are cluster bombs that made
invented by some demon they drop little
colorful balls like this they look like
toys and they scatter around they don't
all explode on impact they will often
just sit there and it just takes a
passing vibration to explode them so if
the kid picks one up or even if a bird
flies overhead or somebody walks by then
they explode and send it send the person
in to shred the person to bits and all
around them so we are against
international law dropping cluster bombs
in the urban areas all over Iraq and
have been for quite a long time and
that's one of the reasons why there are
so many mutilations among the Iraqis
with I heard so many soldiers say to me
understanded I kept seeing these babies
with no arms and you know children with
one leg but the other kids are fearless
and they go up to the soldiers all the
time and they beg for food and water and
they laugh and play jokes and and the
soldiers their hearts of course melt and
this has been one way in another way in
which some of those soldiers have been
able to get rid of that dehumanizing
habit that they're in but the majority
need it because it's it's a protection
that every soldiers ever had more and
when you you know look at all the names
that soldiers invent for their enemies
whether it's gooks or kikes or or Hajis
in the case of the Iraq war or you know
there's always really insulting
dehumanizing word and this war is no
exception
I'm gonna ask you if you have anything
to ask me in a moment but let me just
run over here and see if there's any
other main points I want to make oh yeah
I want to talk a little bit about why
it's so hard for women to report the
sexual assault and harassment and so on
because this is a huge problem when you
look at the statistics that have come
out from the Defense Department they are
they say few thousand every year but
then they admit that 90% of these
assaults are never reported ninety
percent so they're only counting the 10
percent that are reported and the reason
and the reason they know this is because
if you go to veterans who are free of
the military then you get the real
stories and the numbers that they report
you know a wildly different and though
and the reason is that the military has
a culture that's deeply and
traditionally misogynistic
if you think about it perhaps the last
bastion of the male super figure hyper
masculinity is a soldier I mean what
else could be more classically male than
the soldier even more than a minor or a
firefighter or a couple and there's been
great resistance specially among the
older generation to allowing women to
advance in the military they didn't
really want women there at all maybe
it's okay the nurses and you know
secretaries but and this this antagonism
towards women's seeped through every
part of the military so for example in
boot camp one of the classic ways that
drill sergeants and drill instructors
break down their soldiers to build break
down the civilian in the soldier to
build them better people back up into a
soldier which is how they talk about it
is to enrage them by taunting them about
how their girlfriends and wives are
cheating on them and how they're all
sluts this is absolute routine and then
the you know the denigrating words used
to insult and enrage the recruits are
all either you know homophobic slurs or
to call them girls or pussies or ladies
or a lot more vulgar words I shouldn't
say right here for women just being
called a girl we called a woman is isn't
himself and they the methods used I go
into the methods used in basic training
in the in the book because they are very
carefully thought-out and there to
create warriors out of people who
wouldn't necessarily want to kill and so
arranging them in insulting them in
humiliating them all the time and yet
they're not allowed to do anything about
it they have to control themselves you
know you can't lash out and punch your
drill sergeant know you're out you're in
prison and and that's part of it because
then all this anger bottles up inside
the soldier and they're
and mourn to a killing machine and the
main thing that's used is denigration of
women so this is so this is it filtrate
so deeply in its lap so throughout so
what happens if you are a woman you're
being called a lady you know what
happens if your your supposed to be
their equal from their comrades in arms
so that no a lot of it actually is
institutional the misogyny and then
there's then other factors like what
sort of man voluntarily joins up you
know it's a lot of the men who want to
be soldiers of men who already are in
love with a hyper masculine idea and you
know and along with that usually comes a
pretty negative attitude towards women
and then when you add to that the
isolation and the general violence
anyway I go into it a lot more here
because it's complicated and there are
many many layers but it's going to take
a very long time to untangle and
meanwhile thanks to the recession women
are joining up in droves in fact more
women are joining up the men
proportionally so we're getting more and
more women soldiers now not fewer
there was a dead big demonstration just
a couple of days ago in Times Square
where a lot of veterans got together and
they made a big sticker saying one in
three warning for you I have some health
warning you know like you have on
cigarettes one in three women raped and
they plastered all over the recruiting
station that their idea being just that
women who sign up should at least go in
with their eyes open and then you know
there are certain members of the
military in the Defense Department who
are genuinely trying to make this better
and work on it there are a lot of male
soldiers who are as horrified by this
situation as I am and I think most of
them are actually and are trying to who
is they they really do believe specially
the ones who fought alongside women
they've seen how well they do they see
that dependable they see that women and
good soldiers and they see them more as
sisters so there are those people
involved as well luckily it's not an
it's not an all male versus female
situation but we still have a long way
to go so I would like to hear from you
and any questions or thoughts you have
on this I wanted to ask you first if any
of you have relatives or friends in the
military and your connection with the
military or should have asked that first
you do what's your connection they're
both gender they're both male did they
ever talk about it this is one of the
issues that comes up when you're a
civilian whether you're a friend
relative or whether you're a journalist
or oral historian trying to get their
stories there's a huge suspicion of
civilians and a deep assumption that a
civilian will never understand you
haven't this goes back many Wars it's
not unique to this I'm sure you've all
heard this you know the world war two
father who would never speak about it
the Vietnam vet who would never speak
about it there's this huge gap between
civilians and military people
that's cultivated it's not only because
I've been through a trauma that you
haven't and so you won't understand it
it's it's deeper than that
the military is very it's very insular
it's it this is our our world and once
you're in our world you don't belong to
that world out there anymore we've we
destroyed the civilian inside you and we
don't bother by the way to build it back
up when you come home we just kick you
out and you have to fend that's one of
the for yourself that's one of the
problems so we've destroyed the civilian
inside you so that you can
only really relate to other other and
military folk and they don't they're all
lazy in fact I've heard this that so
many soldiers I civilians are all lazy
and fat and you know a bunch of pieces
mix sitting around their armchairs they
don't understand that anyway I haven't
faced life and death like I haven't
they're all concerned only with trivial
things and in some cases this is true
there is true on the other hand
civilians and I think specially leftist
civilians tend to think of soldiers as
those dupes you know ill-educated
lower-class blindly patriotic stupid so
willing to be pushed around by other
people won't think for themselves we
have all bunch of stereotypes like that
as well and this had this adds to the
gap between the two which makes it extra
hard for the soldiers coming home from
wars to reintegrate and be understood
make some extra suspicious and extra
unable to talk about it so this is and
so I had to deal with this to a certain
extent because some of some of the
soldiers I met had had an assumption
that I wouldn't understand so you just
have to be very humble and say yes I
don't know anything about it tell me
everything and I wanted to know
everything anyway and this gets back to
the reading to be able to recreate the
feel of the sand sand and the smell and
her feelings from moment to moment I had
to ask those things I had to think of
really detailed questions what did the
sand feel like what's the first smell
you remember of the first colors you saw
what was it like being alone in that
tent what you know and it's specific the
questions a specific as possible to
elicit enough details to create a story
with that's the challenge with narrative
writing and even then I had to fill in a
few things with my imagination sometimes
because they didn't remember sometimes
because they couldn't bear to talk about
it so into the case with Jen
who I read to you about that happened to
her she she said I can't I can't tell
you what it was like first driving into
Iraq that was too horrible
so I read other accounts by soldiers who
happened to be there at the same time
who've written books or journalists who
were embedded with them and I heard oh
and then I found out why because at that
point we she drove in right after our
big bombing campaign and there were
charred and smashed bodies all over the
streets and bits of hands you know
disembodied feet things like that so I
put that in and recreated her journey
and then I said I need to show this to
you to make sure it's accurate because I
basically made it up which happens a lot
in nonfiction and in history writing
historical writing and she read it
probably a sort of I like that and she
said it's right now please don't make me
talk about it or read it again so I had
to use those methods as well so any
questions because it is a nonfiction
book and I wouldn't go so far as to
pretend to be one of those people I of
course the quotes
do you or do you mean why didn't I just
have them talk oh I know I see oh that's
a great question and I'll tell you why
because there's another book like which
is exactly like that called in conflict
which also was made into a play where
it's above it's just interviews with the
soldiers so all you get is their stories
blocks of interviews it's more like
straight oral history and it isn't you
know each one is speaking in first
person and I hate to say this but it was
boring and you know why it was boring
because
those people aren't very good
storytellers that's why you're lucky if
you find someone who who tells a story
so compellingly there you can read it
for pages and pages and you know this is
this is the difference between being an
artist and being you know you have to be
very pure but I felt I want between
editing and my own narrative ability
that I could make the stories more
compelling and keep them the reader with
me better then then if I did it that way
so whenever the quotes were really
strong and compelling I kept them but
when the soldier began to me and oh
repeat herself or put things in a
jargony way or speak vaguely
generalizations and all those things
that kill a story dead then I stepped in
and told a story for her
yes I get asked that a lot
and I had the same thing when I was
doing the rape book because I had was
gathering stories of rapes this is this
is I can't think of it any way of
answering this that doesn't sound rather
soppy so please exactly I was so moved
by the strength of these women I'm very
moved by the strength of survivors in
general in people the human spirit is
really something
it's very resilient and there's
something I found out when I interviewed
those survivors of rape which is that
there was an instinct among them to
reach out to other people who've been
through the same trauma and help them
and to heal themselves through helping
others and this moved me enormous Lee it
was the opposite of a selfish reaction
instead of curling up in a ball for
years on end although some of them had a
period like that but instead of just
constantly seeking therapy and I mean
demanding that people close to them was
sorry for them all the time that wasn't
their reaction their reaction was to go
volunteer for a rape crisis center and I
found the similar thing among these
soldiers they were reaching out a lot of
them to other veterans to help and it
was helping them heal partly because
they were discovering that they weren't
all alone and that you know a lot of the
feelings the PTSD feelings that people
have in spite of all the information
that's out there about about trauma you
still feel as if it's just you and it's
your fault somehow it's because you're
weak you're not a good enough soldier or
in the case of sexual assault but you
invited it somehow you know that you
were to blame that you were flirtatious
that you didn't you know you've you did
something dumb the pressure to blame
yourself comes from the society at large
and from within the military even more
and so you feel like it's all your own
and then when you reach out to other
people you find they're going through
the exact same things and that's
enormous ly comforting and then you can
help them feel better and so that's what
keeps me going because I do find their I
do find their human spirit actually
encouraging and in spite of the horrible
things they've been through and I also
found it fascinating to hear soldiers
who've been there who've chosen to go
there sometimes speak so politically
against the war I didn't expect that you
know that's not what we hear in the
mainstream media what we hear is rah rah
this and rah rah that and the reason for
that is and by the way this is a little
criticism of journalism the reason for
that is as any self-respecting
journalist ought to know is that
soldiers sign a gag rule they're not
allowed to say what they really think to
the press there get thrown in prison
they're not allowed to criticize their
command the mission or the commander in
chief ie the president so of course
you're not gonna get the truth out of
them when their active duty that's where
we get the same every time
soldiers interview we get the same story
that's where you have to interview
veterans which is what I did they're
free to speak the truth and it's amazing
how few journalists have twigged to this
rather obvious fact well it was
different for some of them not all of
them for some of them like Ellie painted
crow talked about a nossa the Mexican
girl I've mentioned earlier Mikaela the
eggs their experience of being outsiders
as women was compounded by the racism
that
experience too without question Ellie
painted crow talked about this white
woman made sure she had and this woman
made up she said she hated anybody who
wasn't male or white so what she would
do is she would demote all the soldiers
of colors from their jobs and make them
train white soldiers who were of lower
skill and replaced them with the white
soldiers and then make the soldiers of
color into the assistance of the white
soldier so she ruined all their careers
and then Mikayla told me that in her
platoon her platoon happened to be
because of where she was from almost all
Hispanic and black and they were always
given the shittiest jobs so I did hear
some of that but not from everybody for
example one of my main soldiers here
Terrace Dewalt Johnson his
african-american she grew up in DC but
nowadays in in Atlanta and she's the
career soldier she's a sergeant and she
came from the very very brutal
background and completely lifted her
whole family out of that now lives in a
very nice suburb he's married to her
childhood sweetheart they have four kids
are all doing really well in school and
she she loves the army and she loves the
challenges of it she loves being tough
she was a convoy commander in Iraq which
meant that she was in charge of up to 25
trucks driving along behind us through
the bomb ridden roads and she's just
going back by the way and she never said
felt that there was any problem about
race but she did say she did come across
problems as a woman and she said for
example you'd be standing next to a man
and there'd be discussion about some
tasks that had to be done and she would
make a suggestion and we completely
ignored and this is not a soft-spoken
woman this is a woman who speaks like
the sergeant she is you really sit up
and pay attention when she talks
and then she'd be ignored and then the
man next to it would make the exact same
suggestion and he'd be listened to and
and credited with the suggestion this is
an experience I've had I'd bet a lot of
females in this room have also had it's
very common but that makes me die really
mad but she did tell me something that
made me wonder because she didn't see it
that made me wonder which she said she
was one of only two NCOs noncommissioned
officers in her platoon and the other
woman was white and she was the one who
was put on the most dangerous missions
and I did wonder about that but she she
didn't see it that way she didn't see it
as a racist thing and I thought you know
but I don't have any proof it may just
also may have been just because she's
really efficient and tough and good at
her job so I don't know but yeah I did
hear quite a bit about that I didn't do
any kind of sociological parsing of it
though because I didn't have a big
enough sample but terms of rape divided
up into ethnic groups or race no I
haven't found any information I know the
DoD divides people up in terms of ages
ages of of a victim age of assailant and
by the way the average age of the victim
is 21 and the average age of the
assailant is about 27 and he's usually
of a higher rank than her so you know
again back to what I was saying before
about people being given an ignored
inant amount of power in the hierarchy
of the military and being allowed to
abuse it with no consequences whatsoever
that's another reason why sexual
assaults are rife from the military yeah
when the way I did in a narrative where
you mean that's a really interesting
question I think it felt more intimate
because in order to recreate it I had to
really put myself inside their
experience you know with if you're just
going to put down what's been said to
you all you have to do is edit make sure
it flows but if you're going to try and
talk about what somebody's feeling and
thinking and smelling you got to get
inside their heads and their hearts so I
would say it made it more intimate
I mean choosing a chronological
narrative you know before during and
after the war made it easier to arrange
and if I'd tried something more
complicated of course people didn't tell
me their stories in that convenient
chronological order they would jump all
over the place so one of the things that
took me the longest was going over their
interviews and chopping them up and
moving them around to fit in shape by
you know the logical shape of their
lives and and as I'm sure you've talked
about a lot in oral history the story
has change you know I went back and
interviewed them several times and they
would remember more or sometimes they
outright lied to me and then change
their Tunes later on because they were
trying to hide things or they're ashamed
of something and that would come out
later and I'd have to sometimes say
that's not what you told me last month
which is the truth
need to know the truth but that said and
I hope I did get to the truth with all
of them but who knows and we all know
how slippery I think memory is anyway
especially in the middle of trauma once
the two things started to happen to me
which made me feel more secure about the
writing of it one is their story started
to echo each other very exactly so I
knew this wasn't just one individual who
happened to have a rough time I heard
the same things people didn't know each
other
overlapping echoing sometimes word point
by word that that phrase that makailah
said to me you know they're only three
things they let you be in the military a
bit jeho or a dyke I heard that same
phrase from a lot of women it's clearly
something that said among women in the
military and the other thing is that as
I did more background research about the
context of the war and how we were
financing and what financing is and the
use of the contractors and how they were
doing it Halliburton and those wonderful
people I began to know what the story
was behind a lot of the things that the
soldiers told me happening to them which
date when they didn't know it so for
example a soldier would say you know I
got off a 14-hour shift and I went to
the chow hall and it was closed because
they only open for two hours for dinner
two hours for lunch for two hours for
breakfast and my shift ended at midnight
so I was starving all night long after
walking working for 14 hours
well I knew why that happened I knew
it's because Halliburton ran all the
chow halls all the meal services for all
the there's a unit of two line Dick
Cheney's pockets all the services for
the soldiers throughout the war they
still are and they couldn't be bothered
to be open longer because they didn't
want to pay their employees never mind
how hard the soldiers were working not
only that they wouldn't vary their hours
and soldiers would wait in these long
long line
under the hot Sun really hot 140 degrees
sometimes after working all day and
they're in their uniforms which weigh
between sixty and a hundred pounds they
carry around with them all the time
they're standing a hundred pounds on
them imagine if you're a woman my size
like several of my soldiers were that's
my weight and the Sun 140 degrees you've
worked for 14 hours you're dehydrated
you're starving and you're a sitting
duck for bombs because you're there at
the same time every day and there were
suicide bombers who took advantage of
this and there were soldiers killed
because of this because Halliburton
couldn't be bothered to alter their
hours so I would hear after story after
story of little things and a flat tire
but there were no tools to fix the flat
tire we had a brand new tractor-trailer
worth hundreds of thousands of dollars
we were ordered to burn it because we
had a flat tire so that the Iraqis
wouldn't loot it or use it I knew
exactly why that was happening so that
made it very useful too because I knew
I'd seen enough and written read enough
to know that these soldiers weren't
making that stuff up but they were all
experiencing that and they knew why and
that would give me a way to transition
into some background explanation of why
these things were happening huge subject
among soldiers very difficult for women
bathroom needs specially terrible at the
beginning of the war when they had no
latrines at all and it's the desert so
there no bushes so what women learned to
do was their take their water bottles
and cut off the top and pee into those
but a lot of them they were constantly
having bladder infections and then when
they would they did build latrines they
would often be four latrines for 200
people
so who wanted to go in there and
actually all the soldiers ended up just
fouling the desert wherever they went in
there like a blast
they called it the litter box it's one
of the soldiers names for the rocket s
it
but yeah it's pretty disgusting
but so that's a big problem and you know
I remember Michaela saying to me I have
a bladder like an old lady's and I don't
know any woman soldier who doesn't even
though I'm 21
the period was interesting I found a lot
of soldiers had been given depo-provera
shots for birth control by the army and
not they're not allowed to be having sex
over there are but they call it
fraternizing in the army which is
completely wrong use of the word but it
means it means that you're not allowed
to have a romance and especially not sex
so of course why are they giving you
birth control well so you won't have
your period dries up your period so
that's what they actually tell me much
easier for you you know if you
after-effects and not pretty the side
effects I mean of that sure yeah yes I
mean they didn't all take the shot you
know they had different methods but that
was yeah not for everybody but for most
people I checked I I thought if you had
to it that's the most common side effect
of it is it stops your period and you
know questionable health-wise oh well I
remember they I don't know if I remember
all the details now I mean you have to
look in the book but I do have a whole
section on it well the military was
using it you know and but they wouldn't
give out condoms under the bush because
that would that would encourage
homosexual sex so it was really wacky
but the soldiers could get condoms on
their own you know one one way they were
use them they would put they would put
them over the ends of their guns to keep
out the sand knotting that conscious
I have kids at home and the family and
their plenty distraction but I will say
I mean I am very reluctant to talk about
the intent to sound in any way as if
it's my problem compared to what these
people go through but I will say that I
had war dreams for you for years so
would come out of my sleep from a
daytime I didn't feel that affected by
it but it would come out of my sleep I
mean there might be I'd be in the Iraq
war
probably also was good to share that
story yeah I could think another thing
it helped and I haven't said this yet is
how important it was for the women to
tell their stories you know that not a
single woman in the book and originally
wanted me to change her name not one
even though they could get into trouble
for things they said I had to persuade
teres to change her name because she
Rhian listed but she didn't want to
they're proud of that what they're doing
they're proud of their service and
they're angry about being justices
whichever injustice it happens to be
that and this is their way of fighting
back standing up to be counted so in all
this book I think I only ended up
changing three names and only one of the
main major characters and the other two
because they were both in battles with
the VA for their benefits and they were
afraid that they would there would be
retribution
they were quoted so they were I think
that helped me because they really they
were so happy to have someone listen to
them and a lot of them were telling me
things they didn't feel they could tell
their families or tell anyone else
almost none of them had had any therapy
and I think it there was a feeling of
relief for them that help helped make it
not just traumatic and awful for me too
I felt I guess in short I could feel I
was helping them a bit which was a
really nice feeling and it helped
mitigate those horrible stories but I
know that it's standard and trauma
interviewing that you know that often
the interviewer suffers too has
secondary PTSD or whatever and should
have an outlet as well yeah
well I never go there immediately of
course and I never asked I have certain
rules I never asked were you raped and I
never say asked what did he do to you
you just should never ask those
questions it's insensitive and it seems
why eristic I would just say we you know
what I started off with the facts when
we deploy where did you serve for how
long what was your job what branch were
you in and then so we get all that down
first and then I would ask them what
their days were like what their teams
were like who they worked with were
there other women they were working with
that would open up a lot right there and
then I would say how did the men treat
you that's all I'd say very open
question and then sometimes they out it
would all come right away and other
times it took more time but there they
were pretty eager to tell me and a lot
of them wrote to me with the stories of
their assaults and rapes initially you
know because they wanted to be heard so
it wasn't very difficult to get them to
talk about it except in one case there's
one marine sergeant corporal she to this
day has never told me exactly what was
done to her but I know it was bad but
she won't talk about it yes very much so
I mean and in fact I already went to a
hearing that also about that issue in
June this was rather astonishing because
I written an article probably the most
radical article I've written out of this
it was called why soldiers rape and it
was published in in these times which is
a leftie magazine and to my astonishment
Congress picked up that article of all
things and asked me to come and talk to
a subcommittee about why soldiers rape
and they were very concerned with you
know what can we do and to make it make
this not happen and to make and we
talked a lot about consequences I don't
think any good solutions have come about
because you know the military has its
own judicial system for one thing it's
like its own country it has total power
over itself and you know whatever
Congress rants and raves about big see
that much effect and it's also very much
up to the individual commander of the
platoon so the individual commander of
the platoon is out there in war and you
know we can jump up and down all we want
over here it's not going to penetrate
and if the individual commander is his
or her because women aren't necessarily
any better at this if their main
interest is to is to hold their platoon
together and their own reputation as
having a spotless platoon there are two
ways of doing it they all have that
interest their two ways of doing it one
is to sweep all reports of wrongdoing
under the rug bribe people punish them
take the whistleblowers transfer them
out clap them in prison whatever this
happens a lot the other is to do do it
straight up and actually follow through
reports of wrongdoing and go through the
proper judicial process thereby proving
that you are a good commander and my
mission in mind some of my lectures to
the people about who are in the military
and and Congress is trying to encourage
the second approach rather than the
first but there are an awful lot of
commanders out there who will just cover
up anything to make themselves look good
it's all about climbing up the ladder
and getting your medals and no and
you've got your little old boys club who
may well be up to other things - like
stealing and black-market stuff and
yes and they do have this method now
where you can you can report anonymously
which allows you to get medical help but
it does not it means that there will be
no investigation no consequences for the
assailant these they have a report and
the test and it seems that the method
now is to is to get rid of them every
two years to quietly get rid of them
so if you report anonymously you can get
medical help and you can get some
therapy but there will be no
consequences and no judicial their
investigation etc as I said if you if
you report with your name then they will
go through the procedure of
investigating but the thing is there's
no such thing as being anonymous in the
military platoon it's like being on a
stranded on a ship with your high school
class you know everybody knows
everybody's business all the time and as
soon as they start doing an
investigation and the fingers pointed at
a certain soldier everyone will know who
it is and then you'll be ostracized
you'll be you'll be seen as a snitch
because that denotes that's the culture
you'll be seen as a traitor you won't be
admired for reporting it that's another
reason women don't report you know
there's a lot of reasons I forgot to go
into and that's another one so it's
pretty rough for women who report there
and they often are are punished or
threatened with counter punishments
that's another thing that happens you
know one woman told me of a rape she was
she was in the Air Force she was
standing guard in Afghanistan and she
put down her weapon in the guard shack
and walked 20 yards away to smoke on the
smoke deck you're only allowed to smoke
in a certain area and you're never
supposed to abandon your weapon in
combat zone but she was so close to it
she thought it wouldn't matter it was
night time somebody put her in a
chokehold
some guy in a American military uniform
and dragged her off and rape
and when she reported it she did
everything properly she went didn't take
a shower she had the rape kit done she
did all the proper things at the end of
her shift and they said okay we will
follow through your report but we're
also going to charge you with
dereliction of duty for abandoning your
weapon which will get you
court-martialed and ruin you know end
your career and maybe I'll end up in
prison would you like us in to continue
your report that's how they deal with it
very often so she shut up but she said I
shut up and didn't say anything to
anybody any other yes yes I mean of
course these women have weapons but it's
very rarely weapon to weapon you know I
mean the men will get catch a woman in
it happens a lot in the showers when
they're asleep
lot of gang rapes you know moments when
they're vulnerable
but I interviewed this one Army sergeant
has been terrific she had the greatest
turn of phrase
she'd say things like yes gods pissing
in my Cheerios this morning she had a
bad day but she but she said there was a
guy she had was lucky enough she was in
the heavy engineering unit big tough
woman
she keeps pet walls that says to give
you an idea but first years but she said
she was serving with a bunch of other
women and they were and there was some
guy who was harassing a lot of them so
what they did is he tended to sleep
really heavily so one morning before he
woke up they tied him to his cot with
dental floss and then they surrounded
him and they fired the gun and shouted
attack and you know he tried to get up
and he couldn't get up and they all just
stood around laughing and after that he
didn't bother anyone so I have heard you
know sort of people taking it on
women taking things on handling things
on there and and a very common thing
among soldiers I mean actually what they
believe in is handling all this yourself
so when there's problems among men
they'll fight it out so sometimes what
women do is you know they get a
boyfriend or a good friend a gang of
guys who are her friend and they go take
care of the man so that kind of thing
happens but you know women it's
depending on a man for protection it
makes them uncomfortable they're
soldiers but that is that is a common
story too but again you know that's if
they take it back it's not so common it
happens but it's not so common because
women don't want to tell anybody that
they've been raped because if they
they'll get blamed they'll be seen as a
slut what they mean I didn't pass them
very well okay I think maybe I can get
Makayla to do it because she she put it
beautifully herself yes this is what she
said there are only three things the
guys let you be if you're a girl in the
military a bitch a hoe or a dyke you're
a bitch if you won't sleep with them
you're a hole if you've got even one
boyfriend and you're a dyke if they
don't like cute so you can't win when I
was in Iraq in the beginning I was
considered a ho cuz I was nice to people
then I realized what they were saying
about me so I became a bitch I wasn't
mean but I had to change so nobody would
think I was flirty I had to change her
way I walked the way I talked everything
the people over there didn't even know
who I was because I always had to put on
an act a lot of the men didn't want us
there one guy told me the note she sends
women soldiers over to give the guys eye
candy to keep them sane he told me in
Vietnam they had prostitutes but they
don't have those in
i rack so they have women soldiers
instead and of course being called a
bitch
I mean being called a dyke is tough
because it's illegal in the army to be
an admitted or outed gay person you can
be drummed out of the military and this
is another thing I found a study that
the last report of how many gays were
kicked out of the military and
proportionally more women than men even
though women are a tiny minority of
troops the charge of lesbianism is used
more against women than the charge of
gayness is against men and you can be
sure that this isn't only against women
who are gay which is bad horrible in
itself but it's also just - it's a tool
of persecution - used against somebody
you don't like whether they're gay or
straight you know it's an official tool
of persecution this list Don't Ask Don't
Tell thing and disproportionately used
against women probably against women who
were threatening in some way because
they're doing well yes yeah one of my
first sources she's very active on this
Jennifer Howe cat named as she's talked
on the campus campus actually yeah oh
yeah well she says what I just said and
is very vehement about the need to
change that and it's been it's you know
this is another thing like the
Pentagon's ban against combat women in
combat there's a really there's a big
gap between the leadership at the top
and the young soldiers in particular and
I only know this anecdotally but I've
heard it from an awful lot of people
that most soldiers don't they don't care
whether their comrades are gay or not
they just care that they're good
soldiers and then they don't they're not
they're not interested in persecuting
them this is among the men so
this ban is absurd from their point of
view you know it's it's very backward
but it's dangerous because it does give
it gives an official way to persecute
anyone you don't like or anybody who's
standing in the way of your career or
anyone you want revenge on gives you
we're getting you report them and get
them into trouble and the military seems
very ready and eager to boot amount we
lost a lot of Iraqi of Arabic
interpreters that way you might have
seen that story because a lot of them
have happened to be gay some of the best
ones and they were kicked out you which
we couldn't afford that
liddie English lady English women are
everybody's corruptible and in this
atmosphere where the command comes from
the top to allow torture and to turn to
actually mandate torture meant that a
lot of people who might not have done it
otherwise were pushed into it and others
were liking it
she was from what I know about her and
what I've read she was not the brightest
tool in the box and she was under the
you know under the spell and the command
of her sergeant who she was having a
sexual relationship who just had
complete control over and she did what
he said but in the military have to do
what he says anyway whatever your
relationship is and I think she was very
much a scapegoat but you know but she
also did horrible things I mean it's not
as if women don't do horrible things
when they're soldiers yeah oh yeah
that's a good point I think that might
you know - yes women now it actually
relates to what Michaela just said about
putting on the front a lot of them talk
to me about that they put on this hard
shell and act really hard and really
tough all the time I mean the men do it
too but for the women it's often it's
more schizophrenic because it's further
from who they are in real life and and
they cover up their real feelings and
they do all these brutal things because
if they don't they'll be seen as a soft
soldier and soft soldiers get picked on
very you know the pecking order it's
like the the bottom hen you know getting
pecked to death by the other hands and
everybody you know all soldiers are
looking
for those weak ones and if you're a
woman you're automatically seen as weak
as well as if they label you gay so then
you have to prove yourself even more so
that you can lift yourself out of that
and I am sure that contributed to it she
wouldn't have had the power to do
anything about it and except she could
have I don't know where could she have
gone who could she have told everybody
she was telling was was for what thought
that's what they were supposed to be
doing torturing these guys that's a good
question too there's a combination of
things I wanted a sample of different
ages different racial backgrounds
different geographical backgrounds you
know I wanted them to be representative
of everybody and because the military is
a is like that but I also wanted the
ones who had who were good storytellers
and who had good had a kinds of
experiences that reflected the war they
reflected and some people were there had
very bland times you know they were in
their minor characters where they spent
my whole time on a base and didn't see
any action they know there was that kind
of war you know some people had that but
there others who went outside of the
base on the roads would see things so
the ones that were the prison guard
military police they did different kinds
of jobs so I wanted the spectrum but
also you know to be absolutely honest
and this is not so scientific I also
picked the ones I got on with best
because because the interview went the
best with them and they opened up the
most they told me the most because we
get there was a simpatico thing going on
and you know they were there was this
one marine major who was
so gung-ho about the war I quote her a
few times and so like myopic I listen to
her I know that that's a point of view
out there and I should have it in my
book but I didn't dwell it on it much
because all the other military books
have that point of view I wanted to be
the different book so I and I'd also
come across a survey that showed that by
2006 80 % of the women serving in the
military in Iraq thought we should get
out within a year 80 percent so I
figured okay it's fine for me to
concentrate on the women who have
problems with this war because they have
a maturity anyway but yeah getting on
with them that's the unscientific answer
reporting the name too
oh oh I see I see what you mean what's
their logic why why if you're anonymous
that's a really good question loser gets
to the heart of the matter in the heart
of the matter is that they feel that if
a woman isn't willing to give her name
then why should a man suffer accusation
in other words they see the accuser and
the accused as equal as do many people
in this country they forget that well
you know saying you're the victim of a
crime is not a criminal act and so big
they basically figure I think they have
an idea that if they don't if they let
everybody be anonymous and they would
prosecute any way that all these women
would be crying rape falsely because
this is one of the great myths about
rape I really think that's the thinking
underneath when I was testifying
Congress they need congressman who was
had a head of the committee I was on I
was talking to him on it told a little
story there was I don't know if you
followed the story of this marine called
Maria Marie Larkin buck who was murdered
by her she was raped by another marine
she reported him she was out home are
now pregnant eight months pregnant and
he murdered her and but and the baby and
buried them in their bodies were found
well he went when this congressman on
behalf of the mother of this young woman
went to the Marines and said you know
she reported this guy she warned you
that he was violent you took the report
the records are all here why didn't you
do anything about it they said oh she
only reported a rape she didn't report
any violence Oh quote unquote so that
that's where and I get caught that you
know Congress that story so that's the
mentality it's the it's back in the
nineteen thirty somewhere
I just want to mention one more thing
talking about writing which is that I'm
now writing a novel about a woman
soldier which is not one of any
particular character but I've taken bits
and pieces from my interviews and made
up the rest and a third of the novel is
in the voice of an Iraqi woman so I'm
now going to the other side which is
feels very important to me
the soldiers talked a lot about the
Iraqis they known of course who could
not feel for them and Jen the one who I
opened with the one who the passage I
read about she was guarding Camp Bucca
which she was the first and largest
American prison in Iraq and she told me
that Iraqi civilians mostly women and
children would come to the gates every
morning because they're the men in their
family their sons brothers and so on
have been arrested and we were holding
them and they would come to get news of
them and so she is working in the
checkpoint she interacted with them
sometimes so this is what gave me the
idea
so my soldier his name is Kate and I'm
the Iraqi girl they're the same age here
both 20 whose name is Naima meet at the
checkpoint and and I go and this one I
am telling in first-person and they both
have their tongues in first person so
that's what I'm doing now